la chose à propos de la guerre est que cela ne fonctionne que si les
deux parties croient qu'ils sont les bons,
la vérité est qu'ils n'étaient pas si différents que nous nous
battons pour récupérer ce qui était autrefois le nôtre
mais à la fin et c'est la fin c'est
juste une ville tu vas  Habituez-vous à les
regarder tomber comme si nous étions en sécurité pour l'instant,
nous devons déterminer notre prochain vote, donc
pas de mouvement suivant et il n'y a aucun moyen
qu'est-ce que nous ne sommes pas ici pour manger ces
porcs sur les crevettes oh ce gars a du
porc  Dieu tu es bizarre
je ne cherche pas de super traits qui
n'ont pas d'importance je ne peux pas combattre ces
gens même avec quoi que ce soit que ta main
puisse faire
c'est le chef ce n'est pas ils chassent nos
amis nos familles et je suis  ne va
pas l'arrêter
[Musique]
plus d'inconfort de gaz
la seule chose qui garde Manhattan
s'effondrera en un tas de poussière
vous quatre les guerres sont New York et l'argent
pas encore
[Musique]
j'entends leurs klaxons
je peux voir que vous avez formé une sorte  d'étang je
te promets de perdre temporairement
[Musique]
ils vont te décevoir Jessica que tu le veuilles
ou non
tu appartiens  là-haut ensemble
content que nous nous soyons trouvés je ne te serre pas dans mes bras
pendant une longue semaine